in armored course 6 you're supposed to
get hit the game is a bullet hell in its
hardest moments and while there is a
Dodge button it doesn't Grant any
invincibility frames there are Shields
but they can't block everything so can
you beat armored Core 6 without taking
damage I'm gonna try
[Applause]
so I'll be using the checkpoint system
for this playthrough what that means is
that if I take damage I will always
cancel that attempt but I won't restart
the whole mission or the whole game I'll
just go back and load my most recent
checkpoint this way I won't be able to
progress in the game unless I take no
damage but at least I won't lose my mind
by restarting the entire Mission or game
whenever I get hit my goal is to prove
if this is even possible and by the end
of the video I think you'll know
so the start of a legal entry the first
mission is pretty easy it's a tutorial
after all
that said I did almost just get shot
there and just looking at these
projectiles you might start realizing
why this is going to be extremely
difficult
the AC that you use in this first
mission is preset We Can't customize it
to make our run any easier we have an
assault rifle missiles and a blade the
blade is definitely a liability but if
you don't hesitate it can be good
that was close but let's keep going
Rex follow the markers so there are
three AC wrecks in this city amidst all
the enemies and I need to attack from
stealth wherever possible
not gonna lie I don't have to go this
way it would be way safer to go around
the outskirts of the city and sort of
avoid combat entirely but I felt like I
had to embrace the fact that I was gonna
be fighting I can't shy away from combat
there's going to be a lot of situations
where I have to fight so might as well
practice
one strategy you see me do a lot is this
where I shoot the missiles hide wait for
them to reload wait for the energy to
come back shoot another Salvo go down
again this sort of peaking strategy is
really the optimal way to play a lot of
fights truthfully though the only real
challenge for this checkpoint is
clearing this enemy camp where there's a
ton of enemies but luckily if you
approach it from behind you can easily
peek them all with your missiles and
take them out that way
but I have no patience so I almost get
hit
a lot of the time when I played it came
down to that famous quote from Sakura
which is like hesitate and you lose you
can't doubt yourself you can't always
play Passive because you're going to
have to perform a lot of the time so
just get in there don't hesitate try to
take them out as fast as you can
transmitting marker go and check it out
that's it try accessing the rack
so I really want to talk about this
pilot and this AC that we're pillaging a
license from here if you look closely
you'll realize that this AC is exactly
the same one that was fighting in the
original revealed trailer of armored
Core 6. as you can see here their call
sign is Raven which is obviously a
really nostalgic word for a lot of
armored Core fans so I'm really curious
to find out who Raven was but we need
their license because it's illegal to
operate on Rubicon without one
I mismanage my energy here and I get hit
so I reload the checkpoint and try again
and again
I tried finding safe places to hide and
fire but there were none I tried to
attack it from above and then it's rotor
blades just hit me instead it's so easy
for this boss to get away from you it's
so easy for it to cut you down with
machine gun fire but with perfect use of
the assault boost and quick boosts and
your blade and good energy management
you can do it without taking a hit
sometimes
confirmed heavy combat helicopter is
down
that's all for our work here today 62
62 here's the call sign from that
license you picked up
Raven
that's your new name here on Rubicon
so at this early stage in the game we
don't have access to the parts shop but
I did pre-order the game so I get this
the Malanda Parts they're pretty much
better in every way although they are a
bit heavier but that doesn't matter
because we can bear the weight and then
you've got to customize your AC I even
came up with like a backstory for mine
so since this is a no hit run I made it
so that I think my pilot never wants to
get hit he never wants his AC to get
dirty he's just got this perfect golden
shiny AC and he'll restart from every
checkpoint if that means keeping the AC
safe I even made a fancy logo not many
people know this but Ahmed core is
actually a in-depth logo creator with
just like a Mech shooter tacked onto it
last thing I do I grab the Ludlow
machine gun from completing training
this is one of my favorite weapons so I
take it with me into grid135
in this Mission Balaam has tasked us
with striking a blow to their rival
corporation which is archivists and
after a few attempts I make it through
the mission without a single
God damn it this happened right at the
end of the mission too and things tend
to get so tense towards the end of each
attempt because you know you're so close
to doing it
overall though I don't know what I'm
complaining about because this took me
about five attempts which is just
nothing compared to what was to come
what's crazy is I just noticed that I
get hit here if you look really
carefully
but it ricochets and it does no damage
when setting up this run I did a lot of
testing to see if armor could play a
part in completely negating damage like
if it's at range and if the projectile
is not doing much damage I could never
get it to do no damage so that's really
surprising to me I think it's because I
might have been assault boosting and
assault boosting actually gives you uh
reduced impact so maybe that's what had
ricocheted to that degree anyway I mean
I didn't take damage so still counts I
use this pillar to sort of block one
enemy while I take out the other and
then pulse blade finishes the job
back at the garage we now have access to
the parts shop so my first priority is
just a second missile launcher for my
back just filling that fourth weapon
slot is instantly a huge damage upgrade
I also hop into training to get a linear
rifle which I take into the next mission
so this Mission sucked for me I mean
that makes a great entertainment for you
I guess which is half the reason I make
these videos and knowing that I'm gonna
put this on YouTube definitely makes it
easier to suffer through these moments
but eventually I get it I'm gonna show
you my full unedited run and I'm also
going to splice in examples of why it
gets so difficult
foreign
so I'm dual wielding these linear rifles
which is a lot of input to sort of mash
those triggers but the reason they're
great is this the ability to snipe
enemies from a really really long
distance you'll see later I get even
longer shots than that my main concern
with these weapons was that they're not
automatic you can't just hold down the
triggers you have to tap them
individually which I was worried would
cause me to play worse but it worked
so in this Mission we're taking out the
Rubicon Liberation Front to have sort of
set up all their artillery in this city
and yep there's the artillery this
section is brutal
a lot of the time that artillery can
just follow you so that's why I'm sort
of weaving through the buildings here
like look at that those avoided
buildings pretty well and I got hit here
a lot I'll show you some examples
it took me a really long time to find an
optimal route through the city you can
see now I'm just sort of floundering but
eventually I found a path that worked
and it was this one
um but here there's missiles following
me so it's still not perfect you can
hear them coming behind you and
sometimes they pre-fire them which is
fun and sometimes I can't even tell what
hit me can you
but the part that hurt the most was this
I made it to the final artillery section
and mismanaged my energy
couldn't Dodge Rage Quit pretty fast
that was rough anyway back to my actual
successful run this section it's another
example where you just have to go for it
like you have to get in there strafe
never stop moving and just believe you
won't get hit
maybe there's a better way of doing this
maybe there's a safer way but the safer
way takes more time and then all of that
gets undone when you get hit anyway and
I'm stubborn so a lot of the time I
won't give up until I'm successful and
usually that's a good thing you know but
the bad part of that is that sometimes
I'll find a route and I'll just be like
no I can do this this is possible when I
really should just take a step back and
reevaluate things like eventually I
discovered by you know thinking a little
bit that I could just manually aim and
take out the artillery installations
like this with way more safety so don't
sleep on manual aiming especially if you
have a long range linear rifle
but this is the last camp and I panic
here because I see the missiles see how
many times I dodge it's funny how you
play worse when the stakes are high but
this time I come out on top
back in the garage we have enough
credits for a new generator a new FCS
and some new boosters as well these are
pretty much just straight upgrades I
don't think there's any real reason not
to get them especially since we can bear
the weight I also pick up a DA Fung
bazooka which is like one of my favorite
weapons what I'm doing now is taking out
that helicopter from a really high point
because the bazooka's projectile is
self-propelled it has no damage fall off
at range so if something's standing
still you know like a lot of the
transport helicopters are in this
Mission it's a great choice and
that's also why I love this run because
making these early missions difficult
actually forced me to think about parts
and building my AC in a unique way and
it really made that matter whereas you
know for most people's playthrough this
will be easy like you won't even need a
second thought for a lot of this stuff
another thing the difficulty makes you
do is explore different parts of the
mission like I would have never gone
this way originally you can just get by
following the waypoints making a beeline
towards the waypoints but it's often not
the best or the most interesting way to
go so by approaching from behind here we
can get to this high point where we can
just snipe all of the helicopters with
the Bazooka pretty safely
that tetrapod in the distance sniping us
that's an optional objective in this
Mission you don't have to do it I tried
but it was really hard but it's still a
threat as you can see that was so close
uh yeah I tried to take that thing out
with no hit but I'm gonna have my fill
of fighting tetrapods later on so I
decided not to go for that
the fifth Mission I attempt is also the
hardest up to this point but what you're
actually seeing now is old footage it's
footage of me attempting this Mission
before I even started my official run
through I tried to do this with no hits
because I wanted to see if this run was
even possible and I figured this was a
pretty good test of that so I did it
with this AC which I'd upgraded to have
all of the fastest lightest parts and
the best missiles I could afford
I eventually overcame this and realized
the Run was possible but when I did my
actual playthrough I realized I didn't
want to just like replay missions and
get tons of credits and spend all my
money on the fastest Parts I wanted to
actually never replay missions and see
if this challenge was achievable you
know without replaying missions and just
in one playthrough so I couldn't afford
all the fastest parts so I'm not moving
fast enough to avoid a lot of his
attacks that means you have to find more
creative ways of taking out this AC like
one strategy that works is this where
you sort of peek around a corner shoot
your missiles get back and try it again
but this is risky because if you get
close to him that burst rifle that he
has can track really well and it's a
huge threat and I got so close to
getting hit there but I wanted to stay
close because of that I saw his impact
gauge filling up so I wanted to see if I
could capitalize on that staying at
range is safer but you're not gonna do
much damage that way and chances are
you'll get hit by a stray bullet so you
kind of have to risk it you also have to
watch out for these homing missiles
which make dodging awkward if you run
into any terrain but after 21 attempts I
get it
next up attack Galia Dam this was
probably the easiest mission in the
challenge thanks to my teammates
great an independent merch
you know this mission is so easy that I
actually think you could let your
teammates handle it themselves it was
also easy without taking a hit the
hardest part is what you're seeing now
but apart from that you just take out
the damn installations and you're done
you don't even have to fight the AC at
the end really probably the hardest
thing in this mission is this optional
objective off to the right here there's
a tetrapod that has a combat log so this
is worth replaying the mission and
getting if you missed it but again I
don't think anyone will really have a
hard time with this Mission especially
since the checkpoint system exists and I
feel like this is a good time to bring
up difficulty so I'm playing this before
release I don't know how hard people
will find this game you know it's hard
to get a sense of difficulty when you
don't have the social context
surrounding it I can tell that they made
a very conscious decision to make the
early missions extremely forgiving like
even if you fail checkpoints are there
for you and really I don't think there's
a way to fail these missions if you're
halfway competent at the game where
difficulty really exists in this game
and it's a lot of fun is in the boss
fights and also in s ranking the
missions if you want to replay them that
way both of those things are challenging
and very satisfying requiring good
Proficiency in the garage and in the
gameplay as well I think my main concern
so far and I haven't played that much of
the game but my main concern is that
these little fights with smaller enemies
don't seem difficult at all
that's very different from the approach
they had in previous armored Core games
where every bit of damage that you took
from minor enemies mattered a lot but in
this game because of the healing system
and the checkpoint system taking damage
from Little enemies doesn't really
matter that much and it's the boss
fights where they've expended most of
their sort of design space for this game
again I've only completed chapter two so
this could change I could be pleasantly
surprised by enemy difficulty very soon
but so far there's a very conscious
effort to sort of ease newcomers into
the game by making a lot of the minor
Encounters in this game very forgiving
so you might have noticed in the last
mission I had a new leg part equipped
I'm slowly getting more credits so I'm
slowly getting all of the lightweight
Parts I can one cool thing about frame
Parts in this game is that you can often
really figure them out quickly based on
who makes the part for example a company
called Schneider makes these aerodynamic
lightweight frail parts that make you
move really quickly so I'm always going
to get their parts at this early stage
of the game and that's important
especially in this mission where speed
can help you evade that the laser that
just got shot at me that thing you can
avoid it pretty easily with most builds
I think but it will depend on your
boosters and your speed for example I've
tried doing this strategy where I
assault boost to the left
with different boosters and it didn't
evade it so you know the strength of
your assault boost spec can matter a lot
in this Mission I would say
[Music]
one thing I've also been doing is doing
each Mission with a different set of
weapons and the ones I chose for this
Mission are these These are single shot
burst rifles and I didn't like them
before this Mission and I still don't
like them they're my least favorite
weapon in the early stage of the game I
think
these are tricky like the linear rifle
you have to single fire each shot which
is very input intensive and if you
charge it up and do the triple burst
your AC stands still while you fire
which is a huge liability at least with
biped legs if you use tank treads or
tetrapod legs then you won't stand still
you can move while firing the triple
burst which is probably a lot better
than the way I'm using them
I love this part of the mission you feel
like such a threat they just dismantled
half of the Strider just to get rid of
you but it didn't work
for the call
in terms of speedrunning this I think
this is the fastest way to do it you
know start on the left side go
underneath come back up the other side
and then disable the generator on top
last the reason I do the generator on
top last is because that's the one
that's actually in direct firing line of
the eye but if you do that one last it
stuns the eye as the generators go
offline so you can use that moment to
approach it instead
[Music]
foreign
there's a couple of good ways to take
this thing out you can do what I'm doing
if you want a bit of risk and sort of
strafe around it and try to avoid it and
maintain your speed in a circular
direction or you can just hang back find
a good platform and sort of peak it with
long range weaponry
if I get sick of just watching this
thing explode it's so good
[Applause]
[Music]
with the Strider defeated you should
have enough credits to pretty much buy
out a full set of new parts in the shop
what's more if you complete training 3
you get a booster a FCS and a generator
that are amazing upgrades this can make
for some really fun builds going into
operation wall climber
[Music]
start by clearing the way for archivists
pretty much whatever build you have I'm
pretty sure this route in the mission is
the optimal one there's very little risk
here
so the build I'm using for this mission
is pretty much perfectly designed to
counter it the alula booster lets us
move at a way higher default speed and
the shotguns it's so fun firing the
shotguns in this game oh my God and then
on my back I have double vertical
missile launchers which are just so good
in this Mission they completely hard
counter a lot of the enemies as you'll
see that's a really important thing to
think about in Almond core is not just
the damage that your missiles do but the
trajectory they take vertical missiles
for example amazing Outdoors not great
inside also vertical missiles might miss
your enemy but if they're slow moving
they'll get hit by the full Salvo as you
see here and that's the strategy I use
build up their impact with the missiles
go in safely with the shotguns get as
much damage as you can then back off and
repeat the process
go
Mouse tetrapod Mt eliminated that's
significantly reduces
when you play this Mission take the time
to take out all of these artillery
installations this Nets you a ton of
credits at no risk and there's a
checkpoint coming up soon anyway so it's
going to save all of that progress from
taking them out there's even a little
secret hidden thing if you go all the
way to the right and look around the
platform also it's kind of secret is
this entrance where you get to attack
from above
I'll have to step up my own game
a numbered Vesper
but remember
another little tip notice how in a lot
of my fights I don't hard lock on that's
mostly because it gives me better free
movement and lets me choose my targets
more specifically but it's also because
we've recently discovered and had
confirmation that not using Target
assist makes your tracking more accurate
as in the little reticle tracks your
enemies and makes sure more of your
attacks will land and I love that this
isn't the game so much because when hard
lock was revealed to be a thing the
armored corpurist in me kind of died a
little bit because that's not how the
older games played you know you had to
manually aim and out maneuver and that
was a big part of the combat but now
there's sort of The Best of Both Worlds
new players will love the target assist
as a thing it will make the game much
more accessible to them however there is
actually incentive not to hard lock at
all times you know the skill cap of the
game is elevated so much by better
aiming being a thing when you're not
hard locked so I'm really happy with how
this worked out in the end
you ready to climb the wall
so the Juggernaut was pretty tough it
has a surprising amount of attacks that
can hit you the first one I had to learn
how to avoid were the minds that it
ejects from behind yeah those got me
killed a lot especially because they
remain on the ground for a really long
time so forget about that and you're
dead oh and then there's these curving
missiles which are hard to see not hard
to avoid but they can catch you off
guard like look at this clip try to
figure out where the missiles are going
to come from
there they are it's so hard to notice
when it shoots them oh and if I ever
found myself at this distance I was just
in so much trouble machine gun fire will
pretty much always get you the trick
really was to assault boost in but you
really have to do it at an angle or you
get hit but yeah eventually I figured it
all out got my spacing perfect and I
have to say the vertical missiles in
this fight are just perfect the
Juggernaut has a weak spot on top so
they are just guaranteed stagger damage
every time which makes this fight way
easier and it's part of what makes this
game cool you know you can Brute Force
the game with one setup I'm sure but the
player who invests time in learning
about different parts and customizing
their AC will just have a way better
time of everything
anyway this is the only sketchy part of
my fight where I have to avoid all of
that and after this it's pretty much GG
back at the garage it's time for a new
build because after operation wall
climber you unlock these the reverse
joint legs which will give us way more
distance when we jump and Dodge which is
obviously very good I've also equipped
the laser handgun that I got from doing
training you can charge it up if you
want to unload a lot of damage or you
can manually fire it I've also got
plasma missiles which do huge AOE damage
and ultimately this build is phenomenal
I'm really really happy with how it
turned out almost got hit there if you
saw that missile
so this mission is unique in that there
are these wrecks that you have to scan
and you have to find at least five of
them and then survive until the timer
runs out or you can find all of them and
potentially end the mission even earlier
so I'll show you how to find all of them
um basically why we're scanning these
logs is because we're investigating who
Rusty is Rusty was the pilot that helped
you in the last mission and this is the
route he took when he infiltrated the
wall and these are all the wrecks that
he left in his wake
a lot of them very interesting from a
law point of view and we'll definitely
talk about them a bit later when you
play though make sure you loot this one
coming right up because it triggers this
fight
Survivor
before everything else
unidentified AC
open fire kill the intruder
this wreck that we're about to scan
gives us a little bit more information
on the AC pilot that just attacked us so
apparently her name was little Z she's
The Liberation front's little sister
apparently but she wasn't around to save
them when Rusty Came Calling
but she is here now like literally she's
in this fight I was so confused I was
like why isn't this empty dying but it's
her she followed me all the way when I
thought she would deagro but she didn't
so watch as I stressfully try to scan
this wreck without her killing me
luckily in retrospect she only really
seems to have a bazooka so she's easy to
dodge compared to all the other ACS with
Kinetic Weaponry but I've never wanted a
faster scan speed more which is actually
something you can unlock in the OS
tuning upgrade I never thought I would
need it but this is a pretty good reason
too
for now I get the hell out of there but
she is still following me which makes
the next section really stressful I have
to say I love her lore and her character
though you can actually fight her in the
arena simulator and there you can learn
more about her so it reads she's a
warrior of the Rubicon Liberation Front
as an infant Ze was taken to Rubicon by
her parents who tempted by the promise
of riches from Coral mining sought to
make an illegal entry to the planet but
they crash landed and only Ziggy
survived she came under the guardianship
of Uncle flatwell of the Rubicon
Liberation Front and the core of an AC
was the young orphan's cradle as she
grew up to become a coral Warrior so I
love her story and I love that it really
suits what she's doing right now which
is like pursuing me to the ends of the
Earth in order to kill me because as she
mentioned earlier she thinks you're
responsible for what happened here
basically
anyway this is the last wreck and she
comes close to me and does this little
standoff but she's too late she doesn't
fire her bazooka
so looking back she wasn't a threat I
should have just fought her initially
however most AC fights are a threat
which brings me to the next issue for
this run which was that I had to enter
the arena
to the arena combat aptitude evaluation
program
[Music]
first subject AC mad stump call sign
Invincible rummy
man I love rummy I think he's the
funniest character I've met so far if
you see him in chapter two you'll know
what I mean anyway the reason I need to
complete the arena is because the arena
gives you OST chips and OST chips can be
used to unlock expansions and a couple
of those expansions give you Shields
that can be used to negate a tiny bit of
damage but to unlock those I needed at
least three OST chips which meant I had
to beat at least two opponents in the
arena and rummy was easy he's got a
chainsaw and a shotgun which are not
threatening really it's the next fight
that was tough index Dunham he has a
bazooka not an issue he has missiles
which can be an issue and he has a burst
machine gun which is a big issue I spent
more time trying to beat this AC than
anything else to this point by attempt 8
I was trying to use my pulse blade to
combo him down it was high risk and High
reward but no matter what combination of
weapons I tried I couldn't find a
reliable way to stun lock him
indefinitely on my 18th attempt I
equipped dual machine guns and tried to
outdo his FCS tracking at close range
but that didn't work
by my 32nd attempt I was using dual
shotguns in order to dash out from cover
and deal damage to him and then Dash
back away but because I wasn't Circle
strafing I was getting hit by the
missiles a lot
and you know I must have lost all hope
around the 40th attempt because it's at
this point I tried to cheese it with a
quadruped hovering at the edge of the
Arena but there was no real hope there
as I couldn't find a way to achieve
sustained flight but it was on attempt
56 that I realized the answer had been
with me since mission one the Turner
this appropriately named assault rifle
allowed me to stay at a mid-range where
I was pretty safe from getting hit as
long as I maintained speed by boosting
at the right intervals this plus making
sure that I stayed around the 200 meter
Mark meant that it was possible to
overcome him eventually I want to say
this strategy is so similar to the way
that I overcame so many fights in
previous armored Core games and it's
cool to see that it's still intact
finally I could go to the OST screen and
unlock this pulse armor this gives me a
barrier that absorbs a pretty small
amount of damage but in a challenge like
this that's huge but it still wasn't
enough to beat this guy and there was no
way I was avoiding his missiles so I
moved on to Mission 10.
expect the unexpected yeah no so I knew
exactly what to expect the enemies in
this level are invisible so you need a
head part that has a really long range
scan ability to reveal them in addition
they're extremely weak to explosive
Weaponry so I wanted to take that into
account too
this mission is given to you by the
Rubicon Liberation Front who are
enlisting you in order to investigate
this Baus Arsenal Baus uh basically the
biggest weapons manufacturer in all of
Rubicon and they sell to everyone so the
Rubicon Liberation Front is alarmed that
their facility seems to have gone silent
overnight
when you arrive there really is nothing
here or so it seems until these
invisible enemies appear and start
attacking you and their comms are
encoded so it's hard to tell who sent
them
there's a lot of intrigue surrounding
who these enemies are and who sent them
but we'll talk more about the law a bit
later I promise
speaking of law though there's actually
a combat log on a rafter above where I
am right now so don't forget to read it
621 down and take a closer look
no doubt about it it's sir
it contains
fix of coral
must have been an underground vein
all this time so this final part of the
mission alone took me an hour and a half
to do without taking a hit and
eventually I settled on this combo a
assault rifle and a pulse blade and I
miss with the pulse blade like half the
time honestly maybe it was a mistake but
for the moments it does work it's pretty
great
so this final part was so tough the
laser beams that these enemies shoot
have fantastic tracking like sometimes
you'll Dodge perfectly and it'll just
hit you that's just the way it works and
on top of that the enemies shooting them
are hard to pin down like if you don't
kill them fast enough they will just
teleport to a completely random part of
the map and then you have to really rely
on your directional markers and your
scan to find them
the hardest thing is honestly just
killing one of them and then every time
you kill one your chances of succeeding
the mission without taking a hit just
improve speaking of taking a hit I don't
know what happened there my ACS got
completely overloaded from nothing but
hey took no damage so Run's still going
the entire time you're taking out all
the mechs on the wall this one bunny
hopping one with a whip is chasing after
you and luckily it's mostly harmless
especially if you stay at range mostly
that one hurt you can tell because I
just kept the pause menu open instead of
restarting again
but not to be deterred I literally got
here next attempts used the pulse blade
again scared of the whip but had to risk
it and
well you'll see
[Music]
now I know throughout this video I've
probably said multiple times like oh
this is harder than anything I'd done
before this was the hardest section yet
still all of it pales in comparison to
the final mission of chapter one which
is attack the watch point
let's go
up until this point I'd never felt like
any of the missions I attempted were
impossible to no hit like difficult yes
tedious yes but impossible definitely
not
this mission on the other hand might
just be impossible and you'll see why
code seven eight requesting backup
wipe them out
in terms of the way I play
um I meant to bring this up earlier but
the reason that I'm able to free aim and
Dodge and fly at the same time is
because I have a controller that has
those programmable back paddles at the
back and by binding those to ascend and
Dodge respectively I'm able to free aim
Dodge Ascend and fire all my weaponry
and considering how much better it is in
this game to play without Target assist
in my opinion you need one of these
controllers to play at a higher level or
maybe mouse and keyboard I'm actually
not sure how good that is anyway back to
the mission my point is that like I'm
trying my best to play out of my mind in
this Mission and nothing so far you've
seen is impossible none of it however
the next enemy the next AC fight is the
closest thing to Impossible that I've
faced yet
see that that's the watch points control
center
the target's inside make your way in
attacking a watch Point
you're incorrigible Handler Walter
how many of your dogs Must Die kill
before you learn
for a no hit run Sula is actually
terrifying you guys will remember back
in the arena I had trouble with an enemy
whose most threatening weapon really was
just a burst machine gun but almost
every one of sula's weapons is just a
nightmare to deal with first the pulse
gun that he has it shoots out hundreds
of Bubbles and these pan out widely the
further they travel and they do travel
really far like you can still get hit by
this at mid-range it's really terrifying
and then at long range I'm pretty sure
he has maybe the most threatening
missile launcher available which is the
plasma missile launcher this thing
shoots three projectiles that track
extremely well and not only that they
will explode in an AOE burst so I found
no 100 reliable way to avoid these my
best bet was to fly then Dodge left and
right and this would only work if I was
in the middle of the missiles trajectory
it wouldn't work at extremely long
ranges because then they would just
explode on me instead thankfully his
last two weapons aren't that much of a
threat he has a bazooka that's fairly
easy to avoid although it's still pretty
quick and he has a missile launcher that
shoots a projectile that sort of
explodes along its trajectory after a
short delay so that's Sula and here's
what I tried in order to beat him one of
my best strategies was staying at
extreme range from him and using the
exact same plasma missiles that he does
by firing these at the edge of his range
I could pretty reliably do damage to him
the problem is that he has these as well
and if you want to avoid them reliably
the only way is to go closer to him and
Dodge through them at a mid-range in the
air however if you go closer to him he
can hit you with his pulse gun so that
strategy fails as soon as you consider
that after a few hours of attempts I
shamelessly tried to the place where I
could glitch Sula you can take him
throughout the entire stage so maybe
something exists but I couldn't find it
so eventually I just went back to trying
to beat him legit I came so close to
beating him one time when I just fought
him with the Dual wielded ludlows and
tried to outpace him and reflexively
Dodge everything but you have to just
play perfectly to do this but this was
possible it was just Within Reach I
could do this but then I gave up I tried
for so long I didn't really feel like I
had the time and you know the real
reason I gave up here is because I
realized I had stopped having fun every
other Mission until this point I was
having a blast but this was the first
time where I really felt like this
encounter comes down to so much chance
rather than skill and that just wasn't
fun for me anymore so feeling kind of
depressed honestly I got the best
attempt I could and I headed into the
watch point I destroyed the sensor which
was holding back this Deluge of coral
and then I remembered the whole idea for
this AC was that it's this perfect
golden AC and the pilot hates getting it
hit and hates getting it dirty but now
it's just been hit it's just been doused
in Coral so what if I make this failure
a part of its story what if I change the
name of my AC to tarnished and cover it
in like rust and literally make it
tarnished so on top of being an Elden
ring reference it's also just so fitting
for this build and after that I felt a
lot better about all this I was like you
know I actually got hit by Sula on
purpose so in a better mood I absolutely
obliterated boltaeus I had so much fun
in this fight because it was so
liberating just being able to take
damage again and being aggressive and
taking him out that way
and then I was browsing through all the
new parts that you get for clearing
Mission 11 and one of them I remembered
was these hand equipped missile
launchers and I started thinking you
know I had really good success against
solo with two sets of missiles what if I
had four so at the start of this
challenge I laid out the rule that I'm
not allowed to replay missions with
newer parts that you get after that
mission but I broke that rule just so I
could say that it is possible to defeat
Sula without taking damage because I did
it and it felt so good as for boltais is
it possible to do baltius without taking
damage that was my next question and
honestly as crazy as it is for me to say
this I think it is possible I think
someday John Rubicon the chosen one will
find a way to do this and if chapter one
isn't impossible then perhaps the rest
of the game isn't people either and
while it might not be me that achieves
this I think I've answered a part of the
question I set out to answer at the
start of this video so is it possible to
beat armored Core 6 without taking
damage I don't know but I know it is
possible to beat chapter one so so far I
think yes it is possible but yeah I hope
that happens I hope you enjoyed watching
this video I had such a blast doing this
play through and right now there's a
good chance I'm live on Twitch streaming
my first playthrough of armored Core 6
I've only completed the second chapter
of the game so everything beyond that is
blind and everything before second
chapter I'm going to upload a 100
playthrough up on my second channel so
if you miss the stream you can check
that out I think that'll be entertaining
as well other than that please subscribe
there'll be tons more armored Core 6
content to come I'm loving this so far
and can't wait what's in store
but thank you for watching
I'll see you next time
foreign
Raven
you need rest
but first a warning
the coral surgery were swept up in
that was just a glimpse
a premonition of the storm of flame that
will burn Rubicon